- You know, President Obama,
once when I had him on the
you know I called him
the week he announced
before anybody knew who he was
to invite him on the
Tonight Show, you know, and
'cause everybody thought
Hillary had it in the bag,
you know, so he came in and he go,
"Jay, my name's Barack Hussein Obama
I'm running for president
of the United States."
I said, "Okay, well let's
look at the odds here.
Black guy named Hussein from Chicago.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
Nobody ever heard of him.
Ah, you're gonna win pal.
You're gonna be a shoe in."
You know, and you know, he was very funny.
He had a great time.
(Kelly laughs)
So he and I became friends and he gave
he gave me his cell phone number.
So I said, one day I'm telling my friend,
now you know how this is
when you come from a small town
you have the same idiot
friends your whole life
that you grew up with, you know.
So I'm telling my friends, you know,
"I got Obama's cell phone."
"Let's call him up."
You know, I go "We're not gonna call him."
He goes, "You don't have it, nuh-uh."
"Uh huh."
"Nuh uh."
I'm a, like, 45 year old
man, and we're going,
"Nuh uh, uh huh, nuh uh."
Okay. So finally my friend
said, "No, you don't have it."
I said, "First of all
it's probably shut off
since he's President."
"Well if he shut it off, let's call it."
I said, "What time, it's
three o'clock in California.
Okay, so it's 12. All right."
I dial the number.
I hear, "Barack here."
"Oh, Mr. President? Yeah, it's Jay Leno."
"What can I do for you, Jay?"
"Should I throw this number away?"
"Good idea, Jay."
(audience laughs and claps)
- I was like, you didn't have a plan?
- No I had,
I didn't think he was
gonna answer the phone!
- Oh my God, you have,
"Oh, well I was just calling
about the crisis and,
and if you needed any help,"
like, you know. (laughs)
- Exactly.
- Oh my God. (laughs)
None of my friends care what I do.
They don't care whose
number I have. (laughs)
I'm not cool. Your friends
still think you're cool.
- Well, no, they don't
really think I'm cool.
But, but you know what it is
- It's pretty cool to have Barack
- When you have the same
idiot friends that you
- 100%.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I mean, I'm not calling them idiots.
So shout out April, Mary. (laughs)
- I'm, I'm calling mine idiots.
- That's a guy thing.
Girls aren't like, that's cool.